foreign
opportunities in AI have increased
significantly in recent years the search
in jobs related to AI is legitimate due
to its widespread involvement in crucial
Fields according to indeed the pay range
for jobs involving artificial
intelligence is between 160 thousand
dollars to three thousand fifty thousand
dollars and can go even higher so
come up with a list of leading career
opportunities in artificial intelligence
along with companies hiring for those
roles but before we begin here is a
question for you who do you think is
currently needing the AI Market let us
know in the comment section below so
without any further delay let's get
started starting with our list we have
robotics engineer an engineer in
robotics create prototypes constructs
and test machines and updates the
software that manages them additionally
they investigate the most affordable and
secure way to make their robotic system
aspirin should have a bachelor degree in
computer science and pursue a career in
robotics with additional training or
certification in automation is
advantages robotics engineers are in
high demand with 9000 plus job openings
in India and 8 000 plus openings in the
US top companies like Amazon Bosch and
flybase are hiring robotics engineers
but salaries as high as hundred sixty
thousand dollars in the US and rupees 27
lakhs in India next up on our list we
have product manager the role of a
product manager is to recognize and
express user requirements market
research and creating competitive
evaluations and also creating a
product's vision and putting emphasis on
a product strengths and qualities
freshers cannot join as a product
manager it requires basic experience of
two to three years in the field of
product and software development
according to indeed.com an average of
2000 plus jobs are currently available
in India and 20 000 plus job vacancies
are there in the US with top companies
hiring are Tesla Amazon TCS sprinkler
cognizant Etc with a salary as high as
160 000 per year in the US and rupees 20
lakhs per annum in India up next we have
data scientists they mainly deal with
lots of data extraction of Knowledge
from all collected data is the subject
matter of data science it was also voted
the sexiest job of the 21st century good
news is there is no need for any special
degree as a data scientist you need to
have knowledge of machine learning
programming in Python are Java and
mathematical modeling being a fresher
you can join as a data scientist too
data scientists are in demand with 17
000 plus vacancies in the U.S and 3000
plus vacancies in India and big
businesses like accent enter TCS IBM
Google JP Morgan Deloitte Bank of
America recruiting data employees with
salary going as high as two hundred
thousand dollars per year in the US and
rupees 15 lakhs per annum in India
moving forward in our list we have ai
data analyst data mining data cleaning
data interpretation are the three main
tasks of an AI data analyst data
cleaning allows for the Gathering of the
necessary information for data analysis
and AI data analyst make inferences from
the data using statisticals tools and
techniques you need a bachelor degree in
computer science or mathematics to work
as an AI data analyst to get this job
you must have a thorough understanding
of regression and be able to use Ms
Excel according to indeed.com there are
currently 700 plus AI data analyst jobs
available in the United States and 16
000 plus job vacancies in India with top
companies like Accenture IB am we Pro
TCS and capgemini recruiting them and
salaries going as high as 100 000
dollars per year in the US and rupees
8.5 lakhs per annum in India the next
job opportunity in AI is business
intelligence engineer a business
intelligence developer's main duty is to
take both business ends and AI into
account they evaluate complex data sets
to identify various business Trends they
assist in boosting a company's earnings
by planning creating and sustaining
business intelligence solutions to
become a business intelligence engineer
you are required to have a bachelor
degree in mathematics and computer
science according to indeed.com there
are 8 000 plus job available in India
and 5000 plus job vacancies in United
States companies hiring are Amazon
Development Center IBM AWS Etc with this
salary going as high as hundred thousand
dollars per year in the USA and rupees
15 lakhs per year in in India coming to
the top three jobs available in AI at
number 3 we have machine learning
engineer artificial intelligence is
known to include machine learning it
runs simulations using the varied data
provided and produces precise results
they are constantly in demand from the
businesses and their position seldom
goes unfilled they handle enormous
amount of data and have exceptional data
management skills the ability to code
use computers and understand mathematics
a requirement for success as a machine
learning engineer a master's degree in
computer science or mathematics is
highly preferred the necessary
technological Stacks include python are
Scala and Java a deep understanding of
neural networks deep learning and
machine learning algorithm is very
helpful coming to job opportunities
lastdoor.com predicts 13 000 plus job
vacancies in the US and 27 000 plus jobs
available in India with with companies
like mathwork Google Amazon Microsoft
Azure IBM Etc hiring them with salary
going as high as 150 000 per annum in
the US and rupees 10 lakhs per annum in
India coming at runner-up position we
have data architect data Architects are
it Specialists who utilize their
knowledge of computer science and
database architecture to assist and
analyze an organization's data
infrastructure fresher graduates cannot
become data Architects a bachelor degree
in computer science and computer
engineering or related subject is the
absolute minimum requirement to become a
data architect data Architects are in
high demand with 52 000 job vacancies in
the United States and 7000 plus jobs in
India and top companies hiring data
Architects are Amazon IBM Tesla Intel
Wipro with the average salary quite high
as two hundred thousand dollars per year
in the United States and rupees 21 lakhs
per annum in India and Topping our list
of job opportunities in aie's AI
engineer AI Engineers are problem
solvers who create test and use various
artificial intelligence models they
manage the AI infrastructure well to
create practical AI models we use neural
network knowledge and machine learning
methods these models enable one to gain
business insights which AIDS the
organization in making wise business
decisions
ug or PG degree in the field of AI or
computer science is required in addition
to that you can hold certifications from
any reputed organization which will add
up to your resume please check out and
enroll to the AI program by simply learn
in collaboration with Purdue University
the link is provided in the description
below job openings for an AI engineer
are quite high with 35 000 plus job
vacancies in the U.S and 4000 plus jobs
in India and Tech giants like Accenture
TCS IBM Google JP Morgan Deloitte Bank
of America recruiting them with salary
going as high as 200 000 dollars per
year in the US and rupees 10 lakhs per
annum in India with that we have
completed our list of top career
opportunities in AI do you think we have
missed any popular jobs in AI let us
know in the comments below hope the
session was informative and helpful so
what are you waiting for the importance
of AI is bound to grow higher and higher
in the future nowadays people are much
more inclined to the field of AI start
learning AI to land your dream job check
out the AI course curated by simply
learn in partnership with Purdue
University the link is in the
description box below until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here